The joe rogan experience,
but then the same guy will call
mission when he was like, okay,
give me one for my private collection.
And so that's where they would have all
the way more explicit stuff. Yeah. They,
I mean they didn't have
pornography back then,
so they must have been beaten
off to paintings and stuff.
It had to be, yeah. Yeah.
I mean had to be thought of as being
arousal inducing. So much so that,
what was it during the Victorian
era where they put legs of tables,
they would put dresses on them.
Yeah.
They would wrap it the legs of the
tables because you know they are legs,
they are Bayer. They may give you
ideas, which I don't know about you man,
but you know, look at the leg of the
that that really doesn't wait for me.
So the lemon law, something to it
where people got so horny, right.
The table leg, smooth skin.
But that's what you're doing.
You really have problems.
Right.
When you look at the leg of a table and
you got all excited, he's like, man, yeah,
that's not good. No, you'll revisit your
life choice. That's up until that point.
It's fascinating to see. People must've
agreed to that too. What's up Jamie?
I just looked it up.
It says it,
that it originates from a satire
that was written and people,
I guess took it as truth, so it's
not real. Yeah, I supposedly not,
but they definitely did cover the lens.
I think they did,
but the reason why this exaggerated,
since he was poking fun at Americans
that did something like that,
I'll come up this point of the meat.
The meat is too cool.
That's prosperous farmhouse parlor
in 1900 and that has it covered.
But this is 19 hundreds,
right? This is, um,
the Victorian era is when
they did this. Oh wait. Okay.
1839, an Englishman wrote
a satire of American tour.
He wrote the American propensity to
use the word limb and place of leg,
though he says the English two a two.
Then he says that he visited a boarding
school, young ladies, New York Strip, we,
sorry,
square piano forte with four limbs.
Their mistress of the establishment had
dressed all these four limbs in modest
trousers with frills
at the bottom of them.
He's exaggerating or not subjects,
uh,
is exaggerating or not
subject to speculation.
He certainly poking fun or
whether whether Mur, Mur, Mur,
Yat Maryat is exaggerating or
not is subject to speculation.
He is certainly poking fun and Americans.
But I can attest that having
page to dozens of books
showing old black and white
piano photos of Victorian
Interior as I saw,
not one example of a table piano or any
other piece of furniture with skirts
around the individual legs.
That's interesting. Boom.
I liked the legend so much back there.
Hadn't you always heard that?
I thought that from professors.
I remember hearing that from a history
professor. I'm old off the, you know,
between boring history and a fan
legend. Are we signing? Yeah.
I would like to think that people
were way more stupid than they were.
It makes me feel good about
this error. Exactly. We're
in now. Yeah. You'd be this.
Um, I mean, you look at the
dresses that people had to wear,
you know that when all the
way down to the ground,
I mean this is not really much different
than what we see in the Middle East.
It's, it's very simple. I mean,
what we see in the Middle East,
they have to cover their face.
They hit job and the whole deal and
the headscarves and that's a little,
little more extreme, but not much.
Yeah. I mean they, they wore shit.
They went all the way to the ground.
If you showed any ankle would lose their
mind. It's an ankle. I crazy. Yeah.
Well, you know, reputation does it. Yeah.
I wonder if they were more
hypersexualized than we are. I bet not.
I bet because of porn we're probably
more hypersexualized. Right. There's,
I think different arguments there because
some people say the more you write,
the rest of the more than
you're going to obsess with it.
So that's all you think about all day.
[inaudible]
he's less likely to obsessed.
Then again,
there are vaults of people are so
addicted to Internet porn that,
I don't know if that idea works,
but you know, that's the, well,
Internet porn is the problem that an
airport is, the availability is this.
You don't even have to go some way.
At least back in the day when you had
VHS tapes or DVDs or something like that,
you had to go to a store,
you had to buy him,
he had to put them into the TV at a sit
back and get the remote control. Yeah.
There's a process. There was work
involved minors to have minor work,
right? Yes. Now it's just far
too easy as far as, I mean,
how many people that work that
have jobs go into the bathroom,
locked the door and beat off.
That's,
there's a lot of people listening right
now but are doing exactly that in that
right now. You're beaten off right
now. Stop it. Go back to work.
Jesus is watching. That's what I hear.
Yeah. Um, it's just, it's interesting,
I guess if you have to think about it.
Like they were trying to control those
people and trying to control their urges
because it was beneficial to society.
It was beneficial to society that,
that these people needed to do their
fair share and get to work and they
couldn't just be staring at
legs all day and, you know,
engaging in an impure thoughts and, but
you know, that's the, that's the problem.
We any kind of probation,
it's completely misunderstanding of the
human mind works is you do not say no to
seeing says you are not
going to do it is yep.
Guaranteeing that people
are going to obsessed with
this. Right. It doesn't work.
There's um,
how's that sad story that I heard
was that I thought he was hilarious.
I can't remember where it already, but
like guy goes to a zen master saying, Hey,
I'm only going to be called at peace
and happy. I want to be just like you.
What do I need to do? Said master
says, okay, just for the next 24 hours.
Don't think about monkeys,
guys like Walton keys. Never
flipped about monkeys. Him.
I was that gonna make me a light and
send my myself. Dot. Shut up. Go Away.
Come back in 24 hours. Don't
think about monkeys. Okay. Like,
okay well be cutting a light and he's
going to be at peace of gay cause all I
have to do is not think about monkeys.
And of course the next 24 hours become
the most monkey field thou shall slide.
Cause that's the one he got to think
about. Right? Floyd being the bore,
you make sense and get taboo.
The boy,
you've guaranteed that people that
are to obsessed with it. Yeah,
it's a like he didn't
like drinking at 21 in us.
Right?
It's like growing up,
I don't even know if there was an age
in Italy where you're supposed to not
drink but is not that glamorous.
You know,
is what your grandparents have for
lunch and you know where you are,
maybe 60 year old that you want to try
a little wine and they give you a tiny
beat saying if you have a little more,
you've got a headache. So Jessica,
and then one day you would do got a little
more, you got a headache and you go,
oh shit, you're right. Okay. Yeah,
and you kind of learn how to drink rather
than being like, oh wait, God awake,
cool. Now we got all of these bulls and
people drink. Throw up all over done.
Sales is like, touch hasn't got a
hose. Why are you dwindle? Yeah.
I think there's definitely a healthier
attitudes than Americans' attitudes about
alcohol,
but also like wine is a good way to start.
Like you start off a kid with whiskey
shit, that's not the way to start.
Yeah.
One of my first times I ever got drunk
was on Jack Daniels and took years for me
to smell Jack.
Daniel's not want to throw up.
I'm sure he gets those
triggers in your head.
We smell it like Jagermeister. I
used to smell Jaeger mine. It's like,
and just be like,
Yep.
It's just think about just
getting violently ill.
Your body's trying to purge it from
your system so you don't die yet.
It's to to hide it from kids and
tell them it's that, that it's taboo,
but then you drank it. Yeah.
And then they're like, oh,
can't wait until these fucking people
can't tell me what to do anymore to help
get myself a nice cold glass of whiskey.
Yeah.